today we try over a big old  [Music]  then summer to winter go it milk it's  good without milk it's like breakfast  and dessert all in one but it was high  golden Oreo apparently a bagel with some  spirit anything we've infused with Oreo  I feel like is a win  I'm from the yo-yo New York we got the  bagels but let me see these on real baby  [Music]  [Applause]  it was like something you'll get from  willy wonka factory I don't know if I  can go back to a regular bagel after  seeing this this is just on another  level  it's collagen the big ass Oreo and then  you just got like the cream to the cream  cheese some of it on  Oreo goodness God made a bagel  this would be my god I'll break my diet  for this any day yo I give this into ten  out of ten out of a bagel family that's  with milk or coffee or anything with  your really amazing breakfast and cookie  lover approved well it makes me feel  healthier because it's a bagel pickles  are not healthy that's not how that  works